you've mentioned in prior articles that
you are interested in themes of writing
or wrong so to speak how would you
advise other documentarians or even
their the filmmakers to show quote like
a wrong without actually having a strong
bias toward your own opinion toward it
or is that part of your filmmaking I
mean how can a documentarian stay a
little bit remove from their own
feelings of showing something or is that
part of what makes it fun great is your
strong field yeah I don't think you want
to remove your feelings from your
documentary otherwise you have no
passion to do it the subject matter has
to have some kind of resonance in you in
a very deep way and to try to be
unbiased well that's like doing a
broadcast network news report and
certainly that's not the job of a
documentarian as i see it i think a
documentarian is there to express an
opinion and if other people agree with
it then they like your film and if they
don't then they don't like your film so
with the girls in the band what was it
that structure interested in it and how
did you first serve the beginning
interview what was the first step well
I've always searched for subjects that
have some kind of personal meaning for
me and the the imbalance of male and
female endeavors in this world has a
great deep meaning for me and it's a
subject that has always interested me
I've always been part of the women's
movement in you know the 70s and the 80s
and was very involved with developing a
lot of different organizations that
women that support women so the subject
of a woman's role in the world and how
it's perceived and how women have to
operate in the world to get to where
they want to go is very important to me
and the fact that i come from a musical
family and music has been a very deep
part of my
my life since the very beginning was
another very important thread in the
tapestry of my life so when these two
subject matters came together in this
story it was a natural for me and that's
what attracted me to it and that's what
kept me going for the eight years it
took to make it do you remember some of
the first steps in organizing the film
or going and piecing together who you
want to interview you remember some of
the first things that you do well the
the subject matter was was brought to my
attention by a young friend of mine who
called me up one day and she also is
from a musical family and she said that
she had met a woman who was 80 years old
and told her that she had played in a
big band in the 40s and it she was a
drummer and I said I'll I don't think so
I know all the big ben's and i remember
most of the musicians who were in the
big bands and and never saw a woman play
in any of them and she said well this
woman said that she was and wanted to
look her up so I did and when I looked
her up and discovered that yes in fact
this woman had been part of big bands
mainly they were all women big bands but
that there were all women big bands it
really was was rather stunning to me
because I didn't know anything about
this so I started doing research and the
more research I did the more I
discovered and the more i discovered the
more I realized that I'm not the only
one who doesn't know about this my
husband who's a musician he never heard
of any of these women and then I started
asking other male friends who are
musicians they never heard of any of
them and then I said oh oh there's
something year and that was kind of the
beginning of it and actually I got in
touch with a woman named Roz cron who
lives here who somebody had recommended
to me said you ought to talk to her
because she was a woman musician in the
40s and she was the first person that I
talked to and that started the whole
thing
so how much research would you say you
did ahead of time before you actually
shot your first interview I think we
probably worked for about a year just
developing kind of a concept and talking
to people and getting to know people and
I did go out and interview Ross
personally not on camera but I talked to
her and then I talked to a couple of
other people who were around because I
just wanted to get a sense of if there
was a story here and not only if there
was a story here but if these women were
actually good enough so that they could
have played with any of the big male
bands or that they could have been an
influence on the music and that took me
a long time to really feel certain about
I had to really listen to a lot of music
and and hear what these women were
laying down as players before I really
said wow these women were really good if
they weren't just novelty acts which is
how they were portrayed so that was that
was a very powerful moment when I
realized that would you recommend to
other documentarians that they kind of
almost dip their toe in the water a
little bit get a feel for the subject
find out whether there's enough material
to cover whether they can stay sort of
married to it for years and work from
there or should they just kind of come
with this big grandiose plan and and
commit to it what do you think is the
best approach I think the best approach
is however you feel it you have to feel
it you have to love it you have to be
willing to stick with it and you have to
be realistic about it I think one of the
things you have to ask yourself is one
is there an audience for this and two is
it going to be any funding for it am I
going to be able to find ways to fund
this film and if your subject matter is
so narrow focused that there isn't
anybody who really is going to put money
into it you're going to be a pretty
frustrating ride for a while but if
there isn't
and if there is a way to fund it then it
doesn't matter how long it takes you if
it's your passion then you have to do it
certainly some pre-production helps and
dipping your toe in to see you know what
it's like out there helps but I don't
think there's any one way to do it
you